what was it like was this your first
Super Bowl
as like popping popping where you're
like not like hanging out with Sada like
you're like skill a baby yeah little
baby brought me out
at that ratchet ass party yeah on the
west side at the [__] Stratus Event
Center yeah yes Romeo yeah that was hard
there was a I don't even want to talk
about but a lot of yo Super Bowl man
[__] be scamming these
promoters oh my god oh they said he was
going everywhere oh my God I'm glad our
club was like we are the only club that
everything happened how it's supposed to
happen
he packed it out though no for sure it
was like there was like a future day
party that was supposed to happen
earlier in the day in that same spot
[__] went left he didn't show up it was
bad instead Dre and Michelle showed up
imagine paying to see future performance
Andreas there you're like well at least
we got Drea guys Andrea performing 56
nights that have been a [__]
that had been a hell of a Netflix show
oh my God like hey guys we got Drea but
she's gonna do your favorite future hits
go ahead go ahead
oh that'd be great
that sounds like an amazing time I
actually might have been more happy to
see that me because I'm a dick you know
I've been like this is great I kind of
try to Pat myself like like all my toxic
ways after the future
he's a toxic guy yeah I'll try to be
toxic as human life what's your highest
toxic trait you've uh learned from
Futures influence I tell people to call
me and then I don't answer the phone
like you'll tell them like yo hit me
call me like I get a girl number like
tell her to call him and give her my
number and I won't answer
like I don't I didn't get some [__] like
this like I didn't like been [__]
with a girl like I like I'd be like him
I like my girls like I love him like
damn near all of them and how many are
there
is one at the moment
and then one
all of the ones who are watching are
going to be like I'm the one the one
they you're the one it's her though she
know who she is she knows but my toxic
thing I did like I like be messing with
a girl go by or something like I go buy
somebody something today and then we'll
never answer for the rest of my life
she'll buy somebody something and then
cut them off yeah I like that at least I
gave you a I gave you a uh departing
gift yeah right like here's a lot of
girls think when they meet me that we
about to do it or something you don't
have kids right no thank God right you
gotta just hold off for a while
because once you have that kid it kind
of throws a whole wrench into your game
bruh yeah
a lot of girls think we're gonna have
sexual relations but we're not
I just I'm here for a good time
are you the kind of guy that
wants to know you can [__] and then
that's enough exactly
um
I think that's damn near
it's like about the chase and then once
you know it's like I don't even
I know I could do it now so what's the
point because one day I might want to do
it
um
I like that
shout out to you it's like aha you still
haven't tried a honey pack like me and
Sarah was telling you about no I don't
do drugs it's not a joke this is a drug
it's from the performance enhancer it is
a ped
it is a PD for sure some Berry Bond [__]
but it's almost like
if you let's say you're you're Skillet
baby right you're gonna start probably
smashing famous women soon you're a good
looking kid no I'm married
okay well one day if you're not married
and the opportunity comes for you to
sleep with
a famous woman who maybe you've loved
them
who's single
sweetie's not single I don't like single
women okay sweetie
you might want to do the ped
you might want to hit the bluetooth.com
forward slash bootleg and get a free
month supply same active ingredients
yeah let's go to bluetooth.com you might
want to take a blue tube because then
you just you know you want to be
it's like if steroids were legal right
and you got drafted to the MLB hello
ionies there are no but if you got
drafted to baseball
and it was like 98.99 you would be crazy
not to do steroids you're in the major
leagues you're with sweetie she's the
major leagues you might as well hit that
corner store get that honey pack get
that [__] cracking bro no she don't like
me too much I just told you I'm toxic I
don't want people to like me
when people start liking you do you not
like that yeah damn
that is toxic as [__] I think females
like you more when y'all like them and
you're like I think you're right you
like them or when they don't like you
so that kind of equals a lot of
unhealthy uh toxic toxic interactions
with women damn do you find that Detroit
women are different from women in other
cities visit for sure Detroit women
like
and other cities that cater to to us
like in other cities where I go like
they that's their culture like
um
they damn never die for you do you trade
women yeah they ass under
they ass yeah they're crazy I don't want
to talk about Detroit women I love them
like I love women are women at home hey
we got some of the most beautiful people
ever but they [__]
there's that in what way though I had a
lady drive through my garage
without the door being open
drove through it so she ran through your
house yeah
what kind of car was it how much damage
are we talking my garage was damaged car
was like front end damage
I didn't ask [__] what did you do to her
to make her behave in that manner I
loved her
the right way
and she obviously loved you back enough
to be angry enough to commit a felony he
knows that was love though what do you
think that is
lust obsession
to you're I mean if you gotta if you get
mad enough for you say I'm going to
drive my vehicle into this person's
house and risk my freedom [__] up my car
[__] up their house
they gotta love you I'll be having some
toxic stuff going on is that the
craziest thing a females done to you no
but I don't want to talk about the other
crazy stuff the girls and dear to me
well when you got shot it wasn't a girl
that shot you right no okay I got a baby
double check you know I don't know who
shot me still don't know no
was it like wrong time wrong place type
[__] or do you think they were looking
for you I don't think nobody was looking
for me I'm gonna say you strike me as
the most like mellow like mannered dude
when that happened it was scary for sure
yeah
but best bullet that ever happened to me
only bullet right yeah
and let's keep it the best bullet though
why I got richer it helped out I think
so I would like to think so
I mean when 50 Cent got shot nine times
it kind of yeah people were like yo 50
you heard about 50 I shot nine times
this guy I think I like to consider that
but I wish I had it like the bullet I
was like I could just put it in the
trophy case or something that's fire
that's a million dollar bullet